[Music]
what are your parents like are they sort
of performer types or funny types um
they're fun they're fun but they're like
unintentionally funny like they're kind
of like the Costanza from Seinfeld my
parents like right
recently my my parents have used the
term circle jerk in a conversation
what's my entire life they have no idea
what it means why are they using that
phrase don't say things like I went to
the grocery store and I had to return
something they sent me to three
different counties it was a real circle
jerk my parents both your dad said when
got an oil change I said I had to pick
up the next day real circle jerk I got
the definition so I had tweeted recently
that my parents were using this wrong
and I didn't have the heart to tell them
and then some one of my mom's friends
saw it and told her and then I get a
call from my mom
and she's like I had no idea I looked it
up in the urban dictionary that's
disgusting and my dad was having none of
these look what are you talking about I
told your mom about Circle Jerks
it's fine it's live it's nothing it just
means that you getting jerked around in
a circle
so maybe it's completely fine to use it
that way I may be your dad's right maybe
he's gonna try if he sticks with it
maybe it's gonna become this accepted
thing that we can all say I hope are you
guys on board person yeah not on board
for circle-jerk are you on board for the
phrase show man this show doesn't air I
gotta bring this stuff you were - you
had an incident at a restaurant recently
that caused a bit of an issue for you a
little bit I had no idea what I was
doing so I went - and you're being
honest you had no idea what I seriously
had no idea right so I it was one of
those restaurants where they give you
crayons and they're really for the kids
talk about the kids but you know what I
will tell you I love it when I'm in a
restaurant and they bring crayons for
the kids all I do is draw I love what do
you like to draw with her
I draw just little cartoons yeah yeah I
was doing the same thing and I draw I
drew like a smiley face and the bus boy
came over and like every time he came
over to fill up the water he's like huh
and kept on giving me this weird laughs
what is happening then the waitress came
over and she's like okay okay and then
we walked away and then I looked down at
my smiley face and realized that it was
very phallic and I had I've been drawing
I thought you didn't mean to do this at
all right yeah you didn't mean to do it
you're sure you didn't mean to do that
that's like a caveman's pour it right
there that's what that is that's ancient
for today I've been drawing like a
smiley face on a penis with a lip like
since I'm a kid yeah smiling penis right
you got to get that straightened out I'm
gonna it's a real circle